hunting berg wagon works hunting berg indiana if
you thought the automobile and truck and replace
the old-fashioned wagon you're only 99% correct
and that other 1% means plenty of business still
to firms like this here they go on buying and
aging the finest oak in a curry for wiffle trees
coupling poles and other wagon parts whose names
to most of us are at best something we used to
hear our grandfathers talk about this is an axle
in the Mickey Hollywood property men come here for
authentic wagons from all periods of American
history but the bulk of production is not for
show purposes most of the 6,000 wagons turned
out each year are used as they have always been
used for long hard work around the farm they do
have some tools that were not in use when the
company built its first wagon nearly a century
ago like the cutter that turns the axle shaft
next comes the operation called setting
the skeins on the axle when the woods
been pressed in like this nothing short
of breaking the metal will pull it loose
spokes are driven into the hub the same
way once in place in the metal the dry
wood expands under ordinary humidity
and you've got as tight a bond as you
can get this is called a wheel spider
it lacks a wooden rim and a metal tire
they dress the wheel rim it comes in two halves
the two halves are hammered and pried onto the
spokes meanwhile as the wheel nears completion
in the blacksmith shop they prepare the tyre
we think of a tyre as being of rubber but
this was the article that first or that named
metal and would meet on the setting machine a
few operations like painting the stripe on
the hop and the wagon is ready to pull out
and oh let's not forget a wagon doesn't
pull out it still has to be pulled wagons
carried our ancestors through a wilderness
and across the plains to open up a whole
continent its pleasant to know that they
still have a place in the scheme of things